[Music]
it was to me I got the privilege of like
spending ten or fifteen minutes in each
of your rooms and I was pretty blown
away by just the level of conversation
the ideas questions that were generated
so this is a bit of a tall order to try
and surface the the wide variety of
themes and ideas so what I've been asked
to do is keep your comments brief okay
because I know a lot of you know we
could restart many of those very dynamic
conversations so really just try I'm
gonna I'm gonna go break out by breakout
we've just got about five or ten minutes
for each one so we'll keep it tight and
and really try to pull out just an
insight or two that was really you felt
critical or really important to your
conversation that you feel like the rest
of the group could benefit from and
thank you for the facilitators and note
takers in the room both of you played a
really important function and the note
takers were very furiously taking notes
so there was tons that I think will be
played back to everyone so we'll just
we'll just be able to touch on some
things some of the things that came out
okay so for for this dude Chris who is
facilitating Mario was in the group the
first one around or whichever number it
was around social capital second one
who's got something that came out for
them that was a an insight or an idea
they'll take back so okay I got to sit
in on it let me tell you what came out
with like what I got to sit on and I
think there's it's a cross-cutting theme
across all the groups and it's what you
said near the end there around the shift
from a deficit to an asset based model
and how intuitively we all get that
that's good but how on the ground that's
not happening so let's talk about that
for a second around what it really neat
what needs to happen for asset based
approaches to really take hold so what
were what were a couple of the ideas
that came out in that group yeah so the
the context was a simple idea that but
even though we were all familiar with
the notion that
that we ought to think about the
low-income communities that we serve
containing assets as opposed to deficits
that we're trying to address when it
comes to thinking of ourselves as
service providers we precisely think
about people in terms of deficits as in
if we see and you need we think well
what can we do to serve that need and
therefore what do we need to do in terms
of getting new grant money or so on to
serve this new need rather than a model
in which we see and you need and we say
well what can the other people in the
community do to help that person or that
set of people or the community as a
whole address its own new needs you know
there were some model in which social
capital which is one of the researchers
in the community becomes the tool
towards addressing their problems and I
think what's difficult about that is
that cognitively if you're trained in
service provision your training service
provision right the whole point is that
you're supposed to be the server's the
server but I think that model actually
ends up being counterproductive in many
contexts the family independence
initiative is an initiative that
actually tries to do exactly that this
is based out of Oakland and they're a
group where if you as an individual come
in to ask for help the first thing they
say is no we don't help individuals go
back and find I think I'm selling I
think it's five in go back in five or
five other families that have the same
need and then come back and talk to us
so in other words go find your network
in your communities because you have the
assets and when you return then the
question is okay what do you all think
that you need in order to serve your
needs and so again it's not a model in
which you provide but in which they as
an acid-based entity is called the
family independence initiative and I
like that kind of notion that you you
also talk about a group around like
getting over feeling like you're
abdicating responsibility by sending
people away but actually there's there's
obviously greater value and I'm you know
I'm gonna jump actually to another group
because I think the Cynthia in your
group to me it connects to the notion of
system navigators that you talked about
so maybe you guys could say a little bit
more about that conversation and
potentially because system navigation I
just led a session last week with a
whole bunch of system navigators so I'm
really interested in kind of the
insights that you guys had a group
around some of the
the potential drawbacks of system
navigation as it relates to kind of
deficit versus asset approach yeah that
was certainly a salient theme in our
conversation around service navigation
and not just system navigation and
service navigation but navigating all
the different systems that we interface
with and Deana spoke about mapping out
all the different points of access that
children and families have across the
different systems and how do we use a
common language so that when a family or
child comes here and there and then
there and then there to access the
different services and programs that we
all know that we're talking about the
same thing and that for the family they
understand that we're all using a common
language and the value and having that
but also one of the other points around
service navigation was part of that is
also building social capital so how do
you use service navigation to help build
that social capital and that social
cohesion within communities and within
families and I think that that project
is really interesting we have a lot to
learn from that as we think about some
of the system transformation that we
have happening here in Toronto and
across the province as well and I heard
Daniella say I don't know if dantana
just about do you want to add kind of
that comment about the onus well I think
what he was saying and what we can all
agree is that why we need system
navigation is because we have poorly
designed systems or our systems are
designed in silos and so you know
somebody can be in a mental health
system or a special-needs system or an
early learning system or an education
system and that's it's so complicated
even within those systems if those
systems have helped to develop
navigation for their clients okay but
what the fact is is those systems need
to interconnect hence the Toronto child
and family system network you know and
why we're trying to do this you know
because it's because we're we're
creating such an onus for families and
we're actually creating the burden you
know we're creating their deficit
through that rather than making systems
more seamless and more apparent and more
integrated so as good as we get at
system navigation what we should be
doing is designing systems that can
navigate themselves and and that notion
of like putting the burden on on
other ruse as opposed to sort of taking
responsibility I'm gonna go to your
group for a second like you know what I
heard in what you were saying Candice
and and others were talking about
through about the ladder and kind of
putting the onus back on youth to kind
of fix themselves you want to say more
about that I thought it was such an
interesting point yeah there's this
tension this is nothing new it came up
in terms of self esteem interventions
decades ago in terms of who do we focus
on in terms of our interventions right
and it's a pretty simple idea but as
soon as you start shifting some of these
interventions that are being pushed
right now in terms of light touch kind
of nudges to kids or building capacity
and kids are charged with kind of
ignoring the broader issue of the gross
inequality so it is it helpful to train
a kid that the world is you know they're
higher on the ladder than they are right
is it is it helpful to create a bias
perception in the kid the other way so
we have to be careful when we go in and
try and kind of bolster up confidence or
bolster up feelings of belonging so
there's actually a some sort of match to
the community right so the the
intervention target isn't just that sole
individual it might be their network it
it's the larger community so maybe these
light touch interventions need to scale
a bit there's other thoughts from
Mario's group we can also go more
broadly but but anything else that came
out on social capital that that you want
to raise or that yeah please I can just
bring it to our group yeah okay is that
um I we we kept coming back to social
capital so if you're asking that
question now and that all many of our
systems and many of our programs
particularly we're talking about whoa
why CCF see transformation family
support transformation and never know
that acronym Ontario early years Child
and Family Centers they are providing a
service absolutely and a needed service
and they are bringing services to
connect to families all great stuff but
maybe what they're primarily providing
is an opportunity to build social
capital and to kind of name it and call
it that or think yeah and while we're
developing our system to think that
that's a really important aspect not not
a nice to have you know it is what it's
doing and so that I think that's a
different way of thinking about space
and also when we're talking about how we
share space so all we talk about
community hubs and we have new new
efforts on bringing people together and
stuff but maybe all we need to think
about is that all of that all of that
space is really an opportunity to build
social capital and so what goes in it
irregardless let's start there and then
let's fit with the neighborhood needs
why do you I've you or somebody from the
group that was outside they know having
a very dynamic conversation about
resource allocation what are some
thoughts that came out of your group
perhaps related to the social capital
piece I believe it was Donovan and I
don't know if he's in here currently but
we were talking about about the
evaluation capacity of public sector
decision-makers and the use of evidence
in making these decisions and he had a
couple of great examples of basically
using participatory action research to
build the evaluation capacity of public
sector decision-makers but also
presumably build the social capital of
those communities that are involved in
that kind of research so partnerships
being really important and I don't think
that participatory action research is
thought of primarily as a way of
building social capital but perhaps
inadvertently and that is what it's
doing you find that Mario Candice in
designing research to build social
capital is that an implicit or explicit
goal a lot of the research on
interventions designed to build social
capital I think end up showing very
limited effects because they're focused
on trying to essentially make people
become friends you know and and part of
the thing that I think is important in
this context is social capital is a good
in its own right but it's quite
difficult to get people to build social
capital just because it's eager to sit
in someone right people will do it when
in the context of childcare center
because they'll do something for their
kids that they might not for themselves
or because they know it's important for
a larger thing that they worry about or
because it's a way to save money in
other words it's the activities it's the
result of the activities that gets you
there but it's the activity cycle to the
social capital
work together do you want to say
something or did you want to go I was
just thinking in our group the question
came up around thinking about what other
countries like thinking about the the
graph that you had canvas on your one of
your slides and looking at where
different countries sit and so the
question came up about what other
countries are doing right that are
further up there so there was discussion
around that but I was thinking about
that as I'm sitting here and we're you
know talking about social capital as
well and there's an interesting study
that was done from Bhutan in Africa
where it took the developed the index
that designates countries as a developed
country or a developing country which is
usually related to GDP and economic
scenarios metrics and it exchanged that
with indicators of one's happiness
community related indicators basically
things related to happiness social
capital etc and and then they they
mapped them out and it was really
interesting because it flipped and those
that are developing countries are
suddenly developed and those that are
developed are suddenly developing so as
I'm sitting here I was thinking about
that and thinking that two things one
there's a lot that we can learn we often
compare ourselves to developed other
developed countries but in terms of even
doing jurisdictional reviews we could
learn a lot from other places in the
world and then here in Toronto we have a
wealth of assets of people who are who
have grown up in those countries who
have brought that concept of community
and social capital with them and finding
a way to tap into that and learn from
those experiences I think would provide
a wealth of knowledge as well all right
we've got a few more minutes who else
has has a comment or thought something
that came out of their group discussions
just staying on the theme of social
capital one of the things that we kept
sort of coming up against is how do you
measure that how do you measure that as
a system so as the City of Toronto for
example when social capital be a great
indicator that we layer onto our map
we are doing system planning and and
when we are planning for the
implementation of Ontario earlier Xin
child and family centers and thinking
about measurement and data and data on
children it's just it's so important to
layer those on top of each other so how
do we measure social capital and what
are some of the opportunities that we
can use either as a system to measure
that like the City of Toronto or for
agencies to measure that as well I think
you know the thing I would add is when
we start to measure and map we're very
careful about this at the individual
level when we have children and privacy
of these but these communities also have
rights and they can it can become
self-fulfilling prophecies in some ways
too right so when we're mapping we tend
to map the negative things right and so
I think finding metrics on positive
things for communities to strive to and
to create those maps is equally as
important and you know being careful
about about you know how members of that
community understand and and see those
as moveable metrics I think social
capital is one of those you know
community involvement you you mentioned
a couple of them in kind of your
positive metrics but you know kind of
reporting out and interacting with the
media and the community on those you
know finding these hotspots of success
and rewarding those yeah I mean you're
probably way ahead of me on this but
it's just right right so so I know that
one of the key messages out of all of
this is about empowering individuals and
on the other hand it also sounds like or
you know powering also sounds like
you're doing it for them so whatever the
right were to be the individual level
change I know in some of the groups you
also did talk though about at that
system level like if it's if you know
how do we make the systems easier how
would do it I was struck by your comment
I think you said that you shifted from
psychology school to the public policy
school so I'd love to hear more to kind
of set the stage for this part around
you know what made that shift in how are
you seeing kind of the public policy
opportunities here at least we can also
end on a hopeful note and for others as
we kind of take it up to a system level
like where are
of the kind of hopeful opportunities out
of all this I guess part of the comment
was related to thinking about kind of
yourself as someone who wants to do good
in the world
and the best use of time as you kind of
navigate being on the front line whether
it's in researcher and service stepping
back and trying to think kind of more
theoretically and careful with these
things and then you know moving back you
know moving back and in what direction
you want to take and so I said you know
for myself it was really developing kind
of a deep expertise in psychology and
then getting to a point where I wanted
to be reengaged you know I hadn't been
on the frontlines with kids for a while
and so moving for me it wasn't realistic
to go back on the frontline service but
it was to go into a public policy school
where you were forced into the frontline
in various ways through your students
through you know engaging with the media
through having to translate what we're
talking about kind of in our own circles
and silos right and being I think
purposeful about that and kind of career
development and thinking about we often
here as service providers about burnout
but often it's just kind of refreshing
or taking another direction right and in
keeping the the end goal of of you know
where you want your career and your
efforts to to end up and then it's not a
failure to step out a frontline service
for a while you know it can be kind of a
real improvement for for you in the
communities you serve to come at it from
another angle
yeah so I think there's been a couple of
moments that have been inspiring here
right thinking about the number of
agencies in Toronto that are actually
thinking and a forward way so I don't
know if you know how unique you are a
man Mario and I looked at each other a
couple times and went you know even
we've been around the country you know
it's been over four agencies in just the
level of kind of investment in forward
thinking around engagement so I think
you all should be everyone in this room
who was here and committed to this issue
and is thinking in a forward way about
engaging at the community and serving
kids in this way thank you I think in
terms of the public policy research
around housing it's complicated as
you've heard for the social mix idea but
I think there are positive stories and I
would encourage us to find those right
and I think we can only find those
through collecting the right kinds of
data and the data is there we're in this
big data world now that those data are
there but oftentimes we get to the end
point of saying all right we pushed and
we've gotten this this early
intervention is now active in this area
of high need that's the success maybe
maybe not right the real success is kind
of documenting how those kids that lives
are affected or those families that are
affected every day and developing the
evidence base that can allow you to
advocate for more resources or in cases
you know to make a bigger impact so I'm
not sure that that's a success story but
that would be something that I would
advocate for in terms of kind of just
checking our hopeful assumptions about
what we think works again some objective
data and just never never being
satisfied with with having the program
up and running other thoughts on the
kind of policy or system level front
that kind of you got from your
conversations or have his ideas I just
wanted to mention that in our group in
neighborhoods we were talking about
recognizing the challenges that you're
identifying Candice and the realities
that I think Toronto and thank you for
saying that about
I think we try hard we actually thought
about that as well the fact that access
to services it's going to be a challenge
and unfortunately no one from recreation
is here parks forestry and recreation
but in Regent Park which is the the
flagship which Lawrence Heights is the
next one programs are free at the
community center
it's so in order to allow for access so
so people don't have to self-identify if
they're the poor kid or not the poor kid
right so and I just that's that's just
one example there's challenges with that
example because then everybody uses it
and who actually accesses it at 7:00
a.m. when programs open and the people
who have phone and two computers can
fill up before the people who don't have
to line up at 9:00 so not to say that
there aren't challenges but I just and
I'm sure other people maybe have some
examples too about how how we're we are
trying to be forward-thinking and and
trying to mitigate some of those
realities you know I'm clean like model
schools trying to mitigate those
realities and so that's kind of that
Universal Universal targeted the
conversation I really want to thank
Candice actually for her comments
raising the issues of the broader social
context of justice and how are those put
because in some ways these conversations
about social capital have been long
lived here in Toronto as we've done
neighborhood engagement and school
engagement in doing this in child care
centers however it's a it's another yet
another demand on communities that are
already under stress and when we expect
them to find the solutions without
bringing additional resources in a
purposeful way brings us into the larger
discussions that we have often in Canada
about universalism versus target and
things like that but it all wraps up to
that central point that you identified
of that there's there's a justice issue
that underlines a lot of the work that
we all do I want to thank you for that
maybe one with you Mount was there
everyone's welcome to jump in anytime
the universal basic the universal and
targeted access did come up and there
were in some cases were mandated to
provide Universal services
so you can't just not so there was some
interesting conversation though about
differentiate you can have access to the
basic service be universal but then
having the targeted more high needs
service being targeted and so making
that distinction and there was one
example from public health and they had
a lot of insights about balancing the
universal need to access a service but
beyond the most basic level targeting
where the need is greatest but it was a
it's a difficult conversation in the end
and it also came up about reallocation
of resources and that's a really tough
conversation to have and you need the
evidence base to do that but the
universal and particular kind of
conversation is a part of that
reallocation issue so I know that like I
said we just given the surface of what
we talked about and I want to just thank
you all for your engagement and for the
incredibly important work you do and I
share kind of Candice's sense of it's
left me incredibly heartened by the sort
of sophistication thoughtfulness
data-driven kind of professionals that
are in the room today and and so I thank
you for coming on behalf of CFR and on
behalf of the Toronto Child and Family
network and and Danielli I think is not
here and Mario we thanked but I want to
end with a gigantic thank you to Candace
you know I think I can probably speak on
behalf of everybody yeah thank you yeah
again for coming for the work that you
do for just putting out out there and
instead of pushing the thinking and and
then really setting up the conversation
so well so goodbye and thank you
[Music]
you